les restes et agata mais qu'en ce moment
ben voilà on passe à autre chose bernard
de la villardière mec agathe puisque
tard mais qu'en ce moment toute la
vérité
ah bah oui les fohlen revoir leur aide à
100 alors vous savez quoi dit dit montée
et on va voir si les goûts montée
[Rires]
le papa il entend alors agathe est ce
que vous avez un mec en ce moment mais
j'ai un mail à web ici mais qui dit
contre celle de connard on va donner
c'est ça le mag à gages du zéro alors
hellmuth est ce qu elle moi ou pas
noël dit la vérité non y'a qu'une
question sont bien d'autres questions
sur twitter on ait répondu matters j'ai
la légitimité pour vous aider de quoi
des choses mais on a toujours été en duo
fait pas ce genre
alors je vous le dit j'étais pas là sion
ouf quel âge elles à l'arrêt pour nous
on a eu nos questions en direct aux
tiens on a une autre question directe
d'un ton mais c'est tout agathe rousset
quand le mariage avec eni maria un dos
ah oui à la vie allait bien alors c'est
quoi cette histoire c'est quoi cette
histoire
alors est-ce qu'on a des à ce qu'on a
les photos parce que c'est eux c'est lui
votre mec parce qu'on attendait on va
dire on vous a vu à madrid avec femme et
dénis qui est un mec que vous avez connu
sur les réseaux sociaux
alors on va voir des photos est ce qu'on
a les photos spontanées de taxi en train
d'arriver les photos basquiat - version
diapositives sur quel salaire alors on
va voir on va voir et vous allez nous
dire si c'est lui ou pas ne dites rien
pourtant hellmuth nous dira si c'est
vrai ou si c'est fou el mout je peux
vous dire derrière ses lunettes il voit
tout de beinheim tu peux arrêter de
faire ça il ya le pet airways
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sans rigoler ces normes
je ne sais pas là c'est énorme c'est
énorme
le futur c'est à dire la vérité c'est
d'être écoutés bloch de bischheim août
hellmuth est ce que c'est vrai qu'il a
pété à oui oui merci le disent c'est eux
qui sont dans l'eau deux mois je suis
trop loin
ce vase est à dire que depuis le début
allez on va voir des photos on va voir
des photos en avant même de vaches
grasses qui sont chiants les chéris
alors est ce que votre mec parce que je
vous le dis on a vu des photos de vous
avec moi mais déni j'étais dans les
couloirs d'un hôtel vous êtes allés avec
le madrid quand même est-ce que c'est
lui j'adorais le petit jeune
non mais donc mal on met des nids qui
est un snap chattering beurre qui fait
déjà un flotteur regarder le snap la
loti le décalage horaire de mode est
donc marseillais qui fait des vannes sur
le foot oui je trouve moi très drôle
failli me fait marrer geôliers lui roule
et donc voilà
et donc le 14 février il y avait le
match real péjoré par les habitants mais
les gars et j'ai été invité à madrid
avec ma meilleure amie
nassima pour voir ce match donc nous
nous sommes rendus ensemble nous avons
une chambre en tête de tels ensembles
avec nassimah et parmi les gens qui
assistent à ce match il y avait
également brûlé tiana
parmi les 80 millions il y avait 80 fr 5
ans cède et comme par hasard vous êtes
retrouvé avec deux modèles dans le même
hôtel dans la même chose mais dans la
nuit non
[Applaudissements]
alors oui on a la foi tout bas à thouaré
mélodie personnes vit en région ça
n'aura la foule
ils sont terribles alors oui allez vous
avez pas les photos mais c'est pas ça
les photos on s'en fout lui on aime bien
mais on va voir les photos d'elle et lui
en régie flora sebaoun ttt bon allez est
là elle a rien donc voilà donc est-ce
que c'est lui ou pas et non pas des sous
et donc mais pourquoi alors mais a dû
tout arrêter mais ce que je demandais le
maoût parce que c'est lui ce calmant
j'ai des doutes j'aimerai quand on leur
pose la question alors je lui posais la
question
elle va répondre est ce que oui ou non
la question est simple est-ce que oui ou
non vous avez eu une aventure avec moi
mais déni jamais de la vie c'est pas son
style elle maintenant mais je suis
taisez vous
ça va j'essayais pas la défense vous la
détestez
[Rires]
ou alors je vous pose la question car je
crois qu'il a rien je repose la cerise
avait eu une aventure avec moi mes
débuts je n'ai jamais eu une aventure
avec moi mais déni elle goûte bon ce
qu'a dit la vérité
on me pose des questions pourquoi m'a
fait venir ici
pourquoi année dernière j observais
toutes les missions il y avait moins
sage sûrement le change
est ce que c'est le fait que je sois là
ce soir que tout le monde dit la vérité
mais pour le moment dit la vérité louis
marty smac non test ou même pas par là
qu'il a et elle m'a parlé mal ah oui
ah oui oui est-ce que je vais la dirai
non ça c'est un l'avant q c'est la vente
à what are you est pas mais d'y aller et
on dit ça n'est pas lui mais à la mecque
voilà